interesting time today we saw the stock
rally seventeen percent does that
indicate to you that it deals getting
done no matter what investors have
smelled a bludger well I don't know
smelling blood Trisha's good good to be
on even in the evening from Europe but I
don't ask smelling blood but when Rupert
moves he usually moves successfully so I
wouldn't it would be very foolish to bet
against him I would say the deal has a
lot to offer he creates a very powerful
combination us cable and sports
obviously TV and film globally HBO is a
really interesting asset that I'm sure
Fox can can leverage very successfully
be a very powerful international cable
operation because it raises I think you
you raised earlier in your program the
question about what happens with Sky
Europe and from a digital point of view
it certainly creates a colossus as well
with premium digital imageries of them
our clients point of view I think it's
an extremely powerful combination and an
interesting one they will give our
clients access to a much broader
platform not just in the US but
internationally as well so it what this
actually give do you think more
presumably you know a deal like this
might provide more leverage or is there
any other match that you might like to
see I mean from from your clients
perspective well I think what our
clients look for is look is obviously
global coverage is one thing they look
for the link between what you might call
legacy media and digital media which
this will give as well globally I mean I
i still believe Rupert is the only media
mogul with it mogul with a really global
perspective maybe because he started out
in Australia whereas most of the
companies here in the US of course
obviously started there and has focused
on a very strong US market probably to
the detriment of expansion globally the
roof has always looked at it through the
other end of the telescope suits I think
creates a very powerful combination be
very interesting to our clients
obviously it gives gives both Fox and
Taiwan a greater negotiating power
not just with clients that also with
within cable as well in terms of
transmission fees and the like so very
interesting i think move obviously
driven by chief money to look no money
no no a very good point indeed you get a
lot of personalities really at play here
do you think that the jeff bukas really
did the best thing for his shareholders
by you know spinning off time warner
cable i mean did it make it in fact more
ripe for an acquisition but i think jeff
has been very focused quite rightly on
shareholder value and you could say at
one level is probably done too good a
job going to your point so made it made
it more more digestible if that's the
right way of putting it but but jeff has
done if you look at what's what has
happened at the time warner share price
over the years since jeff has been in
control of the business it's done
superbly well and so certainly you could
make such but he's done too good as
you're the one to get a job in fact so
the expectation is a deal of some sort
will in fact get done do you think that
rubert is the one that's going to win
out yeah well I it's always would say
there'll be a lot of other people who
would be interested in this weather they
will take the plunge I mean Rupert
Rupert has the advantage on roof
inverter has the advantage of
controlling his company has effectively
voting control one of the things that
we've seen post layman is companies
which have that degree of control
actually have been more more ambitious
answer I would argue more successful
actually in doing some of the things
because companies attended to be too
cautious as you and I discussed before
Trish they tend to be too focused on
cost and too little concerned about
expanding the top line and growing the
business now we've seen a bit of merger
activity obviously grow in 2014 which is
against that but and here's another
example of it but I think given the the
control structure inside box and inside
News Corp it gives
murder Rupert Murdoch and and his family
a very strong advantage in getting these
sorts of deals done and taking taking
the views that they're taking with your
firm views decisive views and very
ambitious obviously but it's a unique
time is long term money of these sort of
rates and we were in the 30-year market
last year to think of an ad agency group
borrowing money in 30 year market at
five point six percent if we progress if
we tried to do that today it will be 50
basis points cheaper so it's it's an
interesting time when you can borrow
money but 30 years of these sort of
rates and of course the ten-year market
and shorter market is there a danger in
that is a broader question for you is
Sir Martin Sorrell is there a danger in
that you can borrow money so cheaply and
maybe we're seeing some deals and
happening that you don't want
necessarily to happen or we may look
back down the road five years from now
and saying that was just because the
receipt money available it could always
over leveraged a situation but doubt
even state that the metal family have in
their company in any combination of the
nature we're talking about that they
would take undue risk I think it would
take calculated risk at a unique time in
financial history and you see it you see
with others you know whether a year ago
we be talking about 3G warren buffett
and heights and of course it would be
interesting to see that's another good
example as to what 3 g's next deal would
be we've been promised it will be bigger
than the previous one you see a valiant
with an allegan also driven in a way by
what we're talking about but but
certainly you're seeing transactions of
these nature and i think this is another
example of it somebody taking advantage
of a unique moment in the markets but
also having a very strong vision about
what they see for the future and content
in TV and film cable and last but not
least digital